let me ask a big philosophical question
why do you think there is racism in the
world
oh now you've okay fine you've now
you've asked me a question which I throw
up my hands and I don't know will there
always be why is there tribalism are
humans always finding this way to divide
ourselves and
[Music]
um
how bad of a problem is that it's a huge
problem I don't you know I mean I I
don't I'm not going to pretend that I
know enough
to Grapple in a satisfactory way with
such a question I mean to really grapple
with that question one really has to
have all you know a uh
a very broad
knowledge base in which they can make
comparisons I mean the world's a big
place now from from the little bit I
know about the world and I I I read I
read as much as I can I've been I'm a
very privileged character I mean I live
in a university so I'm reading
constantly and listening constantly
from what I gather the problem of
divided societies is a problem that is
worldwide
there's you know and it seems as though
it seems as though human Ingenuity is
such that
humans will find something
to divide over
you know it might be texture of hair
it might be
um uh you know complexion of skin
uh politically ideology political
ideology if the texture if the texture
if the texture of skin
is the same
it'll then be well
you know you you wear these sorts of
clothes
you speak in this sort of way
um you believe this whereas I believe
that
I mean it seems like a human Ingenuity
is such they will humans will find some
way
of distinguishing themselves and then
they seem to want to embellish the
distinction it's not just a distinction
it's not just you believe this and I
believe this okay that makes the world
interesting you know let's talk about
what you believe and what I believe no
it's usually associated with you believe
this I believe this of course my way my
belief is superior to your belief
and
I want to put you down
and now we're headed towards War the
interesting thing is if I were to step
outside of this whole thing from an
alien perspective visiting Earth
I think America is one of the greatest
if not the greatest countries in the
history of human civilization and I
think that the the line between white
and black the racial struggle is the
thing that
in part made it a great nation there's
something about the division and the way
you alleviate that division through the
struggle for human rights that makes for
a great nation and so it's interesting
that the division is almost the fuel for
the greatness for our discovery of what
it means to be human what it means to be
or what Justice Means of
um and it's interesting that it seems
like there's the struggle that you're
you're where you're elucidating now but
that struggle itself is our search uh a
man's search for meaning and Justice and
freedom I think there's something to
that as you were speaking I was
immediately thinking of
the person who you know most jumped to
mine was The Great Frederick Douglass
so I mean here you have a person who in
my view is one of the great people in
the history of the world
and you know one of the things that
ironically enabled him to become one of
the great people of the world he was
born he was born into slavery his
overcoming
was the very thing
that in a sense made him
this Larger than Life figure and
I think there's something to you I will
say this because a minute ago you
mentioned optimism and pessimism
and
uh
I'd say in the last
few years
my feeling about the United States
has
changed
and it's changed in a somber way for
most of my life
for most of my life
I've been in the optimistic camp with
respect to my view of American race
relations
you know the the optimistic camp that
was the camp that's the camp that
believes We Shall Overcome
uh that's that's Martin Luther King's
camp I mean Martin Luther King you know
Martin Luther King you know hours before
he's killed I've been to the Mountaintop
I might not get there with you
but I've glimpsed the Promised Land
that optimism uh Frederick Douglass
would be in that would be in that
tradition
um there would be other people
uh wonderful good people who would be in
that tradition would you start to
interrupt putting the pessimist account
would you put Malcolm X in them oh and
the pessimistic Camp the pessimistic
Camp is the more interesting I mean
ideological I mean it is it's the more
interesting Camp because in the
pessimistic Camp you have I mean if I
was going to list some of my pessimists
pessimist number one Thomas Jefferson
Thomas Jefferson the author you know
principal author Declaration of
Independence he was also the author of
notes on the state of Virginia
and he said in notes on the state of
Virginia
basically we shall not overcome
uh he talked he said you know
um the black people
will always know
that their forebears were enslaved
and they will always be resentful of
that always be aggrieved by that
Jefferson did not think that we would
ever have in the United States a
multi-racial democracy
he was very critical of slavery now he
was a hypocrite he had slaves he sold
slaves
he was terrible in that way but he did
understand that slavery was horrible
but
he did not want he he all but he he did
not want to free the slaves for a
variety of reasons but in one reason was
because he thought that it would be
impossible to have a society
in which blacks and whites
were
equal neighbors he was thoroughly
pessimistic another pessimist Alexis de
tocqueville
thoroughly pessimistic
so who were some of the other pessimists
Abraham Lincoln
pessimistic that's why he was so
interested in colonization he basically
said you know I don't like slavery but
blacks and whites are not going to be
able to share the United States maybe
the best we can do is just you know put
blacks ship black someplace else can you
elaborate on that I I think people would
be surprised to hear oh yeah you will
put Abraham Lincoln in the pessimist
camp Oh Abraham Lincoln's thoroughly
pessimistic he was like he he believed
he was Auntie he he was anti-slavery
but he did not believe that blacks and
whites would be able to share the United
States together
and he was always very interested
therefore in colonization
even after the even during the Civil War
he was interested in you know maybe
maybe maybe all black people would all
black people be interested in maybe
going to Panama would they be interested
in going someplace else because you know
Lincoln was aware of how racist white
people were including himself
and he did not think that black people
and white people would be able to share
the United States
now there's the black nationalist
tradition you mentioned Malcolm X well
before Malcolm X you know Marcus Garvey
um my father
my father was a thorough going pessimist
his view was a the United States was
born as a white man's country it's going
to remain a white man's country
uh and that's the way it is he was
thoroughly pessimistic you mentioned uh
just a brief aside about your dad that
when you moved to South Carolina to
Washington DC
um and you asked them why his response
to you was because either a white man
was going to kill me or I was going to
kill a white man yes
so he saw race as an important line that
divided people in the United States he
certainly did and he thought that the
line
my father did not
my father had passed away
before the elect before Obama was
elected I would have loved to have
talked with my dad what do you think he
would have said
and you've written you wrote a book
about the Obama press I did I did and I
didn't I never
what would my father has said my father
would have been delighted my father
would have been happy about his election
I do think though
I do think that my father would have
said I'm happy that Barack Obama has
been elected
hold on to your seats
let's see how the white people respond
so he would have predicted I think that
my father I think that in 2016 I think
that in 2016 you would have said I told
you yes
yes I think that in 2016 my father would
have said
all of you people
who were talking about I don't know
what's happened to America and how could
this have happened and you know
no I think my father would have said
this is America being America
and what has happened
is that America has been
put off kilter
by a black family being in the white
house it is deranged millions of white
people and now this is coming home to
ruse I think my father would have
absolutely said in 2016 I Told You So in
2016 uh as you're saying is the reason
that you have at least
dipped your toe outside of the Optimus
Camp into the pessimist Camp I'm I yeah
I want to be careful here and I don't
wanna
don't give up on the Optimus I don't
you're right I don't want to give up on
The Optimist Camp I don't I I it it I
have been
my optimism has definitely been dampened
it has definitely been tested
I am certainly no I'm I am I am not
I am not uh
as a triumphalist as I once was
I am not as indignant as I once was in
my criticism of pessimists
but at this moment as we speak
you know am I more in The Optimist camp
that I'm in the pessimist again I'm
still probably more in The Optimist camp
but my optimism has been dampened
but as I speak
I have to say the following things and
I'd say the following things of my
father but again whom I Revere
great man
but if my father was sitting here with
us
I would say listen pop
uh uh it's absolutely true that the
country is more racist than I had
thought that is true
it's also true Pop That
the vice president of the United States
as we speak is a black woman
as we speak it's true that the Secretary
of Defense
now Secretary of Defense the secretary
of defense is the head of the Pentagon
the Secretary of Defense knows where the
button is okay this is not a little you
know this is not
a small out of the way thing this is the
SEC the Secretary of Defense
is a black man
there are a slew of black generals
there have been black secretaries of
State
there are black people who are the heads
of police forces there are black Mayors
of or you know some of our foremost
foundations
there are you know the the the the the
president-elect
of Harvard University
is a black woman
and we could go on and on and on and on
this is not you know we're not when I
was growing up when I was growing up
when I was let's say 10 years old we got
a magazine Ebony magazine every month
and in Ebony magazine you could turn to
the middle of Ebony and they would have
black firsts the first black person to
do this the first black person to do
this
you could read Ebony and frankly I could
tell you all of those for I knew their
names
now
I read stuff
you know the you know the the the
leading Cadet the chief Cadet
at the you know United States Naval
Academy
I'm reading I'm reading then I see a
picture
black woman
I didn't know that
back in the day I would have known that
now
has the United States changed
yes
uh is there racism yes
uh is it you know a substantial force in
American Life
regrettably tragically yes
has the United States changed yes and
again if we want to go International
the United States is not the only
country that is
a country that has wrestled with
deep division you think about I don't
know think about India think about you
know the United Kingdom think about
practically any large nation state
they've all grappled with divisions
if one asks about the United States and
the race question
and one puts on the table
that you know in
1865. now you know when I talk with
students I say 1865 they think oh my God
you know isn't that when dinosaurs roam
no it wasn't when dinosaurs run 1865
frankly is not all that long ago in 1865
the great mass of black people in the
United States had recently been released
from chattel slavery
the great mass of black people in the
United States in 1865 were illiterate
now
I mean it's absolutely it's it's an
absolutely extraordinary story
and so one of the difficulties I have at
this moment
is wrapping my head around
two stories that are in such tension
with one another one is the Continuing
Story of racism which is an awful story
but the other story
is a story that is encapsulated
in the title of a great book of History
by
um John hope Franklin
From Slavery to Freedom
and you know those are two stories in
American Life
and it takes an awful lot
put your mind around both stories and
I'm trying to well as an optimist I
think you put more value to the
overcoming side of the story
the overcoming of hardship the
overcoming of uh slavery of
discrimination